tiene solo 25 años y se sentará en el
congreso de Estados Unidos
Maxwell Frost demócrata electo en
Florida será el primer miembro de la
cámara de representantes de la
generación Z es decir nacido después de
1995 entre sus temas favoritos está en
la justicia social y el cambio climático
pero su primer caballo de batalla será
la lucha contra las armas fue el tiroteo
en Sandy Hook en 2012 lo que impulsó al
joven másgo la involucrarse en la
política
los millennials y la generación Z
constituyen un tercio del país pero no
representamos ni de cerca un tercio del
gobierno
otra cara nueva en el lado demócrata
John frederman de 53 años quien llama la
atención por su altura de más de 2
metros ferman ganó en un cerrado Duelo
una de las curules para el senado de
Pensilvania aboga por la legalización
del Cannabis y el fortalecimiento de los
sindicatos
[Aplausos]
y fundamental para cada persona la
atención médica me salvó la vida y
debería estar disponible para todos y
cada uno de ustedes
entre los republicanos
uno de los únicos candidatos de Donald
Trump que ganó su elección ahora será
senador por Ohio
Felipe tener a Donald Junior aquí estoy
feliz de tener el apoyo del presidente
haré campaña con cualquiera que nos
ayude a ganar este inversor financiero
saltó a la fama en 2016 cuando publicó
la historia de su caótica infancia en un
pueblo de clase trabajadora de Ohio